So, we want to continue in Volume 8 with September the 2nd, 1908, and we're talking
about virtue.
Okay?
So, I want to give you one John 4/16 to start you off, one John 4/16.
I'm going through bitter days because of the continuous privations of Blessed Jesus.
He came for just a little, and he told me, "My daughter,
the way you can know whether one has charity is that he loves the poor."
That's not a test we would have given ourselves as to how would you know you loved somebody.
In fact, if the person loves the rich and is available to them, he may do so because he
hopes to obtain something.
So, I want you to write beside that the letter of St. James, and it's Chapter 5, and he gives
terrible warnings to the rich.
Now, I think he may be also saying something about it in Chapter 4.
And he brings up the subject.
In fact, he may bring it up in Chapter 1 that the church makes a difference between the
rich and the poor.
The rich are welcomed and the poor aren't.
That is in an assembly.
Okay.
This is exactly what Jesus is going to say here.
That's the letter of James.
In fact, if he loves the rich and is available for them, he may do so because he hopes for
something, or he will obtain something, and because he's in sympathy with them, or because
of their nobility, their intelligence, their eloquence, or even out of fear.
But if he loves the poor and helps them and supports them, it's because he sees in them
the image of God, image of God, Genesis 1, 27, and Genesis 2, 7.
Therefore, he does not look at roughness, ignorance, rudeness, or misery.
Through those miseries, as though through a glass, he sees God, 2 Corinthians 9, 6-9.
He sees God, from whom he hopes to obtain everything.
So he loves them, he helps them, he consoles them, as if we were doing it for God himself.
That's Matthew 25-40.
What you do to the least of my brethren you do to me, do you remember?
This is the good thing about true virtue, which begins from God and ends in God.
So the origin of something will tell you whether it's good or bad.
On the other hand, that which begins from matter, that's earthly stuff, produces matter,
and ends in matter.
I want to give you Matthew 6-24, they've had their reward.
So as bright and virtuous as charity may appear, if the divine touch is not felt, both in the
one who does it and in the one who receives it, they become bothered, annoyed, and tired,
and if necessary, they will even commit defects.
Isn't that interesting?
In other words, there's no grace.
September the 3rd, 1908, Jesus is the light, so this subject is light.
And so what we're going to move on to is that Jesus is also going to say, "I am the light
and I am the truth," okay?
So for, "I am the light is John 8, 12, and John 9, 5."
As Jesus said, "I am the light of the world."
God is light is one John, one, five, okay.
So Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus made himself seen all light,"
one John, one, five.
And said these simple words, "I am light."
But what is light made of?
This is a very important thing.
It's a question people don't think of asking, yeah, okay, sort of thing is light, but what's
light made of?
He said, "What is the principle of it?"
He said it is truth, isn't that fascinating?
So that's John 14, 6.
He said, "So I am light because I am truth," and in John 14, 6, he says, "I am the way,
the truth, and the life, therefore in order for the soul to be light and to have light,"
so that is Ephesians 5, 8, Ephesians 5, 8, and Galatians 2, 14.
Just the subjects of light and truth are huge in the New Testament.
Ephesians 5, 8, and Galatians 2, 14.
It's better to ask me.
In order for the soul to be light and to have light in all her actions, these must come
from truth, not from deceit or duplicity or falsehood or anything else, they must come
from the truth.
However there is artifice, deception, and duplicity there cannot be light, it's only
darkness, 2 Corinthians 6, 7.
And I also want to give you Ephesians 6, 14, and you can go on and on and on.
First Saint Paul says, "Beware of the angel of light," that's Satan disguising himself
deceiving you.
So September 5, 1908, we're going to be talking about the divine presence.
I was speaking with the confessor, Louisa, said, and he was saying how terrible it will
be to see God in dignity.
This is so true that on the day of judgment, the wicked will say, "Mountain's burials destroyers
that we may not see the face of God."
And Isaiah 2, 10, it's a quotation, Isaiah 2, 10, and Revelation 6, 16.
Now in the Old Testament, their fear of God's judgment, they would run into caves and try
and get under mountains and they'd ask the mountains to protect them.
In our day they have built cities underground and they think that everybody else is killed
up above, that they're going to survive underground.
You should read Revelation 6, 16, the Lord says, "I'll find you wherever you are."
So and Louisa was saying, "In God there cannot be indignation, but rather it is according
to the state of the soul.
If she is good, the divine presence, his qualities, his attributes attract her whole
self within God."
That's Genesis 3.8, Genesis 3.8, and Sam 16.11, Genesis 3.8, Sam 16.11.
So his attributes attract her whole self within God and she is consumed with the desire to
immerse herself completely in God.
If she's bad, his presence crushes her, drives her away from him and in seeing herself rejected
and not feeling within her any seed of love towards God so holy, so beautiful, while she
is so ugly and bad, the soul would rather get rid of his presence, if possible, even
by destroying herself.
Now there's loads of references, I'm going to give you a few, Sam 17.2, Sam 51.11, Sam
68.2, and Genesis 4.16, Genesis 4 is Cain not able to take God's judgment on himself,
so in God there is no mutation, but rather we experience different effects according
to how we are.
This is a very important point that she's making here, that we live our entire lives
on this earth, if you look at me for a moment, if you draw a line and there's just two ends
on it, and one end it has mercy and the other end it has justice.
So if you're tending to live a good life, you're living at the mercy end of the spectrum.
If you're living a bad life, you're living at the justice end of the spectrum.
Now in case you think that that unusual, a child grows up between the hugs and kisses
of the parent and the discipline of the parent, and depending on the child's behavior depends
on which end of this continuum they're actually at.
Society is the same, that the people who live at the criminal end know all about the courts
and all the rest of it, and people who are keeping the laws and living a good life may
never see the inside of a court and the whole of their lives.
So it's one spectrum and the two ends, so that's what Louisa is saying, that it depends
on the way we're living as to which aspect of God we actually experience.
So afterwards Louisa said, I thought to myself, that's much nonsense that I said, and then
while I was doing the meditation during the day, Jesus came for just a little and he told
me, my daughter, it was well said, I do not change, but it is the creature that feels
the different effects of my presence as she changes.
So that's what we've just explained.
In fact, how can one who loves me ever fear that Sam 27 verses 1 and 2, Sam 27 verses 1
and 2, and 1 John 4, 18, perfect love casts out fear, okay?
So how can one who loves me ever fear if she feels my whole being flow within her and
form her very life?
Can she ever fear my sanctity if she takes part in that sanctity herself?
Can she ever be ashamed of my beauty if she keeps trying to embellish herself ever more
in order to please me and to be like me?
She feels the whole of the divine being, all of it flow in her blood, in her hands, in
her feet, in her heart, in her mind, just as your whole soul occupies every single part
of your body.
So the Lord's presence will fill your entire being, okay?
That's why you can lay hands on somebody else and the Lord will heal them.
Nothing in my hands, but because the presence of the Lord is in me, he can touch your hands
through me or he can speak a word of consolation through me, my words are no use to you, okay?
People don't realize that when they do the laying on of hands, what's actually going
on and they think some people have what they call healing hands.
Our hands are either dirty or clean, you know what I mean?
No, it's the Lord's presence in that person reaching out to you.
So there's the divine being flowing in all of her blood, her hands, her feet, her heart
and her mind in such a way that it is something that belongs to her, it's fully her own.
Now for that I want to give you Galatians 2.20.
I no longer live, Christ lives in me.
So if Christ is living in me, of course he can speak, he can see, he can hear, he can
touch county, if he's living in me.
And how can it fear or be ashamed of itself that is the presence of God in us?
This is impossible.
My daughter, it is sin that casts so much disorder into the soul and she reaches a point of wanting
to destroy herself so as not to bear my presence.
I want to give you Matthew 25, Matthew 25, 31 to 46.
They end up out of his presence forever, do you remember?
Because Matthew 25, 31 is the judgment.
On the judgment day it will be terrible for the wicked and this is the Lord speaking.
Not seeing any seed of love in themselves but rather hate towards me.
My justice imposes on me to not love them, isn't that scary?
And the persons who are not loved, one does not want to keep them around and one makes
it, some means to drive them away.
I will not want to keep them with me, that is forever.
And they won't want to stay and they will even shun each other.
Love alone is that which unites everything and makes everyone happy.
So for love alone, I want to give you one Corinthians 14, one you must want love more
than anything else.
Now I want to give you a couple of scriptures for the persons who can't stand the presence
of God and would prefer hell, is that okay?
Isaiah 35 verses 8 to 10.
Isaiah 35 is talking about the redeemed on the journey back to God and they say nothing
on clean will be on that road.
That's Isaiah 35 verses 8 to 10.
Revelation 21, 27, which says that everybody living a foul life will not be permitted into
the city of God and that's that.
And Revelation 22, 15 as well says the same thing.
Now elsewhere in these writings Jesus said that Louisa even witnessed it herself, that
if Jesus visited purgatory, even came anywhere near it, the souls would automatically rush
out to meet him but when they would see his infinite purity and holiness, they would have
to draw back because they couldn't face that and they would willingly go back to purgatory
to get more cleansing.
So it's a mutual thing, it's not just God saying I don't want you around, it's not saying
you couldn't stay around.
So September 6, 1908, Jesus wanted to suffer in order to reunite everything in himself.
Continue in my usual state, I was thinking about the mystery of the scourging and as
Jesus came, pressing his hand on my shoulders, I heard him say in my interior, my daughter,
I wanted my flesh to be scattered in pieces that certainly was.
And my blood to be shed from my whole humanity so as to reunite all of dispersed humanity.
You know from the hours of the passion that each one of those bits that fell off his body
represented a soul that was lost.
In fact, of all that was torn from my humanity, flesh, blood, hair, nothing was dispersed
in my resurrection, he got everything back to me.
But everything was reunited again to my humanity.
By this, I incorporated all creatures within me.
That's how it's so easy to pray for them, they're all in Christ, okay.
So after this, if one wanders from me, it is out of his own obstinate will, therefore
you're completely responsible, that he tears himself from me to go out and be lost.
So September the 7th, 1908 is about self-abnegation, okay.
And we're told that the more you deprive yourself of on earth, the more you will have
in heaven.
But the vast majority of people I know would prefer as much as they can on earth, okay.
So the subject of this very important piece is austerity on earth, plenty in heaven.
And that is the reasoning behind people going out into deserts to spend their lives in
abject poverty and loneliness for the sake of the kingdom.
The people going into monasteries and all the rest of it.
So, and for this, I want to give you Luke chapter 9, Luke 9 verses 23 to 26, 23 to 26.
And Matthew 16 verses 24 to 27 and Mark chapter 8 verses 34 to 38.
Mark chapter 8 verses 34 to 38.
Now, in Luke's gospel there's an enormous amount of material on being poor on the earth
and rich in heaven.
And the whole of chapter 16 of Luke is about that, also this chapter 12, you know.
And Luke is the one who says over and over, you know, to give everything away.
So, Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little, and
he told me, my daughter, the more things of which the soul deprives herself down here
is earth.
The more she will have up there, which is heaven."
I think it's fascinating to use that language down here and up there, okay?
And the reason for that is that where we stand to us heaven is up there, and earth is down
here.
So, he's not revealing anything new about the universe.
He's just simply talking about how it looks from where you stand, that's all.
So, "The poor on earth," he said, "the richer in heaven," that's Luke all over the place.
The more she is deprived of tastes, now taste is used in these writings to mean satisfaction.
Okay, so you better write in the word "satisfaction" there.
The more she's deprived of satisfaction, pleasures, amusements, trips, oh, boys.
Our generation are addicted to trips, aren't they?
Strolls.
I'd hate to know what a stroll is, because to me that's gone for a walk on the earth.
The more satisfaction and pleasures she will have in God.
Now, what you do is you take the principle there, that if we live a life in which the
self is being put in its place, and God is being put in his place, that that's the balance
that we have.
Oh, how she will stroll in the expanse of the heavens.
Now, why is she using stroll?
I want to give you a Genesis 3.8, because God walked with Adam in the cool of the day.
That's what you're told in Genesis 3.8.
So she says, "You'll be strolling in the expanse of the heavens."
Now, one of the reasons why she's using that language is that elsewhere in these writings,
Louisa will tell you that she is taken up into the heavens and that she goes strolling
around the place, which is fascinating.
I don't know how you stroll in space, which apparently she did it, but then I don't know
how you walk on water either.
Oh, how she will stroll in the expanse of the heavens, especially in the immeasurable
heavens.
Because that means the heavens above are the Milky Way, the immeasurable heavens are infinitely
further than that, okay?
So the immeasurable heavens is God's home of the attributes of God.
In fact, each attribute is one more heaven, one more paradise among the blessed.
Some enter into them as though at the margin, okay, now before we move on there, just make
sure you know what the attributes of God are, mercy and justice and wisdom and sanctity
and all the rest, and they're all equal, the whole out of the miracle.
So in heaven, they stroll around these aspects of God and they have absolutely infinite pleasure
and satisfaction out of it.
So now we talk about people who are entering heaven for the first time.
Some people enter heaven through the margins of the attributes of God.
In other words, the relationship isn't all that wonderful.
And so they've all their learning to do in heaven.
Some walk in the middle of them, so they've done a bit of work on earth, okay?
And some even higher, I hope the goodness we're a little bit higher.
And the more they walk, the more they taste, enjoy and delight there.
So one who leaves the earth takes heaven, be it even in the smallest thing, therefore
it follows that the more one is despised, the more one is honored, the smaller the greater,
the more submitted, the more dominant and all the rest.
But of the mortals, who thinks of depriving himself of something on the earth to have
it eternally in heaven, almost no one, do you ever call her that?
That's the revelation.
In other words, they mightn't even arrive at the margins, do you know what I mean?
So October the 3rd, 1908, as long as the soul is in continuous attitude of operating good,
grace is with her.
Now you know from volume two that grace is an outpouring of God, Jesus said, I am grace.
Okay?
So this morning, blessed Jesus made himself seen just as a shadow and he told me, my daughter,
as long as the soul is in continuous attitude of working, we would say doing good, okay?
Grace is with her and gives life to all her actions and that's spiritual life, it's divine
life, okay?
It's not physical life.
If then she is indifferent to doing good, she's lazy or she's actually doing evil.
Grace withdraws.
Now there's two things for that, Habakkuk 1.13, Lord, your eyes are too holy to look
upon sin, Habakkuk 1.13.
And then the second one is Hebrews 12.14 that you should know off by heart by now, nothing
unholy or onward they can enter the presence of God.
So as soon as sin comes in, grace goes out, it's actually that simple.
That's like saying, when night comes in, the sun goes out.
When morning comes, the night goes and the sun comes out, either have one or the other.
So if sin comes in, grace goes out and you see, we need very simple statements like this
to keep us really alert to the issues.
So if she's in the act of doing evil, now doing evil in these writings is going against
the will of God, using your own stubborn will to oppose God.
Grace withdraws because it's not something that belongs to it.
The evil can't belong to grace.
And unable to take part in it or administer its own life's sorrowful, it departs with
great displeasure.
Therefore, do you want grace to be always with you and my life to form yours?
If you do, then remain in the continuous act of doing good.
That means in your thoughts, in your words, in your desires, in your actions, we're inclined
to think of doing good as sort of running projects, you know what I mean?
So it's taught words, actions, everything, okay, and his desires as well.
And you can add in motivations as well there, okay.
So you must remain in the continuous act of doing good.
In this way, you will have my whole being developed in you.
Therefore his justice, his mercy, his kindness, his forgiveness, his everything.
And you will not have to grieve so much if sometimes you do not have my presence.
In other words, if you don't actually see me, you'll actually have me.
That's like a child has to learn at some point that they must tolerate being in a room while
the mother is in another room just shortly, just for a short time.
The child has got to realize that just because I don't see her, it doesn't mean she's not
in the house, you know, that's what he's saying here.
In fact he said, "You will not see me, but you will touch me with all your actions."
There's a wonderful text in one Peter, one eight, one Peter, one eight.
Peter says though you don't see him, you utterly rejoice because your faith has enabled you
to enter fully into the presence, okay.
You will touch me with all your acts.
So when we do our acts in the divine, we're touching the Lord at a very deep level.
So whether you see him or not, you're making this contact.
And this will soften in part the pain of the privation he said to her.
October the 23rd, 1908, how divine science is an upright operating.
We would really need a different title, but never mind.
You in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me.
My daughter, all of divine science, now I don't know whether he's saying knowledge
with understanding because that's usually the word I would put there because for us science
means stuff that goes on in laboratory and the testing and that kind of stuff.
In science is divine knowledge, okay, and for someone who is living in union with him,
he will infuse divine knowledge into you.
So it's contained in operate operating.
Operating is working, okay, operate means you have the correct intention.
And you know that in these writings, the only intention he accepts is that we do something
for love of him.
In fact, that which is upright or righteous contains everything beautiful and good that
can be found.
It contains order, usefulness, the word is utility, okay, beauty and mastery.
A work is good in so far as it is well ordered.
This is fascinating because if you look at the beginning of your book, we're on a journey
back into the order for which we were created.
He's trying to take us out of the disorder of sin and the disorder of selfishness into
the divine order where everything can be restored and we can get back to the place where Adam
left off.
So a work is good in so far as it well ordered, but if the threads appear crooked and are
placed crookedly, one doesn't understand anything.
In other words, there's something out of place.
If you're listening to music and there's a couple of notes that are now right, because
the disharmony, the order, is gone, is that okay?
So if things are not in the right place, you can understand, you can't understand anything
and you can see nothing but something disorderly which will be neither useful nor good.
This is why, from the greatest to the smallest things that I have made, they all appear orderly.
I mean all the planets, all the stars, everything.
And all of them serve a useful purpose because the found from which they came was my upright
working.
Now as much as a human being is good, so much divine knowledge will she contain within her.
You can only have it in the goodness, it's given to you in the goodness.
As much as she is righteous or upright, so many good things will come from her for others.
A crooked thread in her working is enough to put herself in disorder as well as the works
that come from her and to obfuscate the divine knowledge that which she contains.
One who goes out of what is upright, goes out of what is just, holy, beautiful, useful,
and goes out of boundaries in which God has placed.
And by going out she will be like a plant that doesn't have much soil under it or the
rays of a scorching sun or frosts or winds that cause the influence of the divine knowledge
to wither within her.
Such is crooked operating like frosts, winds, rays of a scorching sun.
So lacking much soil of the divine knowledge, she'll do nothing but disorder.
Now I don't go down this road too far simply because I wouldn't be able to pursue it.
The physicists and the astrophysicists, so the ones dealing with the earth and the ones
dealing with the sky, all tell you that everything God has made can be reduced to mathematical
statements.
In other words, they are so orderly that they can predict something simply because of a
mathematical statement.
If it works in mathematics, it's out there, otherwise mathematics wouldn't express it.
It's fascinating.
We had a discussion there a week or two ago that an awful lot of things for God are either
round, which is a perfect structure or a cube, a cube is also a perfect structure.
And of course, if you go and look them up on the internet, you will be told how perfect
these signs are absolutely incredible.
And so everything about them is right, the shape, the size, the usefulness, everything.
And you see, when you examine things like that sometimes, you get an insight into God,
it's fascinating.
There is a thing on YouTube about the miracle of mathematics.
I wouldn't be able to tell you where it is because I find these things accidentally.
And it tells you, you know, if you add up certain numbers, just exactly how it all works out
in the most incredible way.
And they ended up when they just started with one and they kept adding things up to get the
same result, they made a perfect pyramid, an absolutely perfect pyramid.
You know, that everything in God's universe is just perfect in shape and everything else.
So November the 20th, 1908, we're talking about love again.
Love is the central topic after divine will because God is love and the divine will is
the operating part of the Trinity.
So continue in my usual state full of bitterness and of privations.
This morning, blessed Jesus came for a little while.
I would lament to him about my state, but instead of answering me, he would draw closer
to me.
And then afterwards, without answering what I was saying, because he loves telling her
little story, you know, and he likes getting on with running the universe.
Does that give you any reflection about male, female?
The detail and the big.
Okay.
Then afterwards, he just, yeah, he said, my daughter, the true loving soul is not content
with loving me with anxiety.
This is terribly important with desires, with surges, but when she comes to make love her
food and daily nourishment, only the energy content.
In other words, that you don't just get bursts of fervor and then you go off, you know what
I mean?
That is consistent day by day by day.
It's then that she becomes solid and serious and keeps on losing all that lightness or we
would say frivolity.
The frivolity of love is that you get these emotional surges and then they die down.
You lose the frivolity of love to which the soul is subject.
And since she makes it her food, it's spread throughout all of her members, because what
you had for your supper will go to every cell in your body eventually.
And because it's spread everywhere, she has the strength to bear the flames of love that
consume her and give her life.
By containing love within her, by possessing it, she no longer feels those intense desires,
those anxieties, but she only feels that she loves more the love that she possesses.
In other words, the relationship becomes completely stable.
You don't need high peaks and low depths at all.
That's sort of early stage stuff and it becomes very solid and you just become aware of the
fact that you love him more.
So this is the love of the blessed in heaven and it's my own love.
Well his own love in Greek is called agape, A-G-A-P-E, agape.
And that was the word that St. John used all the time in his gospel to describe love, whether
it was love for God or love for each other.
He used agape.
And he did that so that he could avoid other words.
You see the problem in English is that we have one word.
And so we use the one word love even if you're talking about lust, do you know what I mean?
So using his word agape, you know you're talking about divine love.
The blessed burn, but without anxiety, without clamor, rather with solidity, with admirable
seriousness.
This is the sign that a soul has come to feed on love.
She loses more and more the characteristics of human love.
That's all the emotional traumas and everything.
In fact, if one sees only desires, anxieties and surges, it's a sign that love is not
her food, that is what keeps you alive on a daily basis.
But it's only a few particles of herself that she has dedicated to love.
So since she's not all love underlying that one, she does not have the strength to contain
it.
And so she has those surges of human love.
I call them the emotional ups and downs.
These I think you need to add the word unstable.
Souls are very valuable and without stability in their things, it says here, in their doings,
their everyday life.
Now the former ones are stable like mountains that never move.
I've given you the references for love many times, do you need them again?
Nobody said anything.
Matthew 22, verses 29 to 30.
John 13, 34 to 35.
John 15, nine.
One Corinthians 13, verses one to three.
And one Corinthians 14, one.
And Ephesians 3, 19 to 21.
Ephesians 3, 19 to 21.
I've given you those references many times.
So December the 16th, 1908.
The privation of Jesus is the greatest of all pains.
Going through most bitter days, I was lamenting to our Lord saying how cruelly you have left
me.
You told me that you had chosen me as your little daughter and that you would keep me always
in your arms and now.
You've thrown me to the ground and instead of a little daughter, I see that you've made
me a little martyr.
And even though little, my martyrdom is just as cruel and harsh and bitter and intense.
Wow, she's able to say it.
Talk about expressing stuff emotionally.
While I was saying this, he moved in my interior because he's there all the time.
And he said, "My daughter, you are mistaken.
Sometimes you just tells her outright she's wrong.
My will is not to make you a little martyr, but to make you a great one."
If I give you the strength, that means fortitude.
Write the word fortitude over strength.
If I give you the fortitude to bear my privation with patience and resignation, which is the
most painful and the most bitter thing that can be found because it's the pain of purgatory.
What's the pain of purgatory?
You've seen him.
You want him desperately and you can't have just now.
And there is no other pain that equates it or resembles it either in heaven or on earth.
Is this not heroism of patience and the ultimate degree in love?
Now, you need to put about 10 NBs beside that because in all of the terrible pain of
the privations, Louisa gave no indication whatsoever that the reason why, well, she
suppose she did if he examined it, that the reason why is simply that she loves him and
she can't be without him.
Now, she does say it over and over again, but you might only hear privation.
You might hear what's behind it.
He said it's the ultimate degree in love.
Now, the person who's saying it is the person who's going to judge her.
I wouldn't mind if he said even half of that to me.
Okay, this is not heroism of patience and the ultimate degree in love.
Now, of all the mystics that I have read, and I've been studying mystics for 50 years,
never come across this, that the Lord ever said that about any of them, including the
great trees of Evelyn, John at the cross of the lost and he never said it.
He said it about this woman, that's all.
That's why I want to point out the uniqueness of Louisa.
So it's the ultimate degree of love compared to which all other loves remain behind are
almost nullified and there's nothing that can be compared or can stand before it.
It's not this then great martyrdom.
You say that you're a little martyr because you feel that you do not suffer so much.
It's not that you don't suffer, but it is the martyrdom of my privation that absorbs
your other pains, in other words, this gets to her so much she hardly notices the other
pains that she has, isn't that something else?
Making them even disappear.
Now in the higher volumes, you'll be told that Jesus will explain that this pain of his
privation is actually a divine pain and that's why it's completely intolerable to her.
In fact, in thinking that you are without me, you neither bother about nor pay attention
to your other sufferings.
But by not paying attention to them, you reach the point of actually not feeling their weight.
You know we say about someone, if they're going through troubles, if you can distract
them, it'll actually help.
If you can just take their mind off something, it actually helps them.
And he's explaining that the pain of his privation has taken her mind off everything
else.
It's amazing.
Therefore you say you don't suffer.
And then, I've not thrown you to the ground, rather I keep you more than ever clasped in
my arms.
Even more I tell you that if to Paul, that's Saint Paul, I gave my efficacious grace at
the beginning of his conversion, that's Acts 9, the whole chapter.
I gave my efficacious grace at the beginning of his conversion to you, I give it almost
continually, that's efficacious grace, that's grace that works.
And this is the sign of it, that you continue in your interior everything that you used
to do when I was with you almost continuously.
Doing what now you seem to do by yourself.
So I want to give you one Peter, one, one Peter, one, eight to nine.
You're feeling all immersed in me and bound to me, always thinking of me even though you
do not see me.
This is not your own thing, nor an ordinary grace.
This is special and efficacious grace.
And if I give you much it is a sign that I love you much and that I want to be loved
by you, that therefore is a very special section where Jesus explains that for the first time
and at that depth.
So December the 25th, 1908.
How to make Jesus be born and grow in hearts, I want to give you John 3.5 before we start.
Finding myself in my usual state, I was longing for a little baby Jesus and after many hardships
he made himself seen in my interior as a little baby.
And he told me, my daughter, the best way to make me born in one's own heart is to empty
oneself of everything, this is VIP.
In other words, it's not difficult to read, it's only difficult to do.
Empty oneself of everything because in finding an empty space, I can place all my goods in
it.
Now that empty space is your nothingness, would you write nothingness over it?
Nothingness, and he can do anything but nothingness because he created the universes out of nothingness.
And only then can I claim it forever he said, if there is room to be able to carry all that
belongs to me and all that is my own, I want to give you Matthew 16, 24.
And I want to give you John 3.30, he must increase and I must decrease.
A person who went to live in the house of somebody else could be called happy only if
he found empty space in which he would be able to put all his goods, otherwise he wouldn't
be happy.
That's not right.
And he said, I'm the same.
But my comment there for myself is, we're made like him.
So before the next paragraph, I have a little heading, the only acceptable intention.
The second thing in order to make me be born and increase my happiness is that everything
the soul contains both internal and external.
Now everything, he emphasizes the everything, so he's not looking for 90%, he's looking
for 100.
Everything must be done for me, everything must serve to honor me and to execute my orders.
That means that the divine will reign.
So everything must be done for me is the only acceptable intention.
Everything must glorify God and our letters will be carried out with us.
If only one thing, one thought, oh dear, is not for me, that's two Corinthians 10, five,
two Corinthians 10, five, every thought must be captured and given to Christ.
Okay.
So if even one thought or one word is not for me, I feel unhappy.
And while I should be the master, they make me the slave, how can I tolerate all this?
So for honor there, we have to honor him.
You see a little bit of the honor, you see it?
I want to give you one Samuel 230, those who honor me, I will honor, says the Lord.
One Samuel 230, S-A-M for Samuel 230.
So the heading for the next paragraph is sacrificial love.
The third one is heroic love, magnified love, love of sacrifice.
So notice the love of sacrifice is called heroic and magnified or love that is really
grown.
These three loves make my happiness grow in a marvelous way, because they render the
soul capable of works which are superior to her strength, now superior to her physical
strength, therefore they come from fortitude.
As she does them with my strength alone, so the human strength can't do it, fortitude
can.
Okay, put John 15.5 there as well, without me, you can do nothing.
And Philippians 4.13, you know, these ones are off by her, don't you?
I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength, 4.13.
So you do them in my strength alone.
They will expand her, that means the soul, its capacity expands, by making not only her,
but also others love me.
And she will reach the point of enduring anything, even death, in order to triumph in
everything and be able to say to me, I have nothing else, everything is only love for
you.
That would be a fantastic moment, wouldn't it?
In this way, she will not only make me be born, but will make me grow and will form a
beautiful paradise for me in her heart.
As he was saying this, I looked at him and from little, in one instant he became big in
such a way that I remained completely filled with him and then everything disappeared.
So December 27, 1908, he wants a heading for this.
This is an absolutely fantastic teaching on The I Love You.
I was meditating when the Blessed Mother would give her milk to the baby Jesus.
I was saying to myself, what must have passed between the most holy mother and the little
Jesus in this act?
In that moment, I felt a move in my interior and I heard him say to me, my daughter, when
I suckled milk from the breast of my most sweet mother, together with milk, I suckled
the love of her heart.
Now, in, this is Volume 8, when you go back to Volume 2 and 3 and she's, Louisa's beginning
to describe some intimate experiences she had with the Lord, she's talking about suckling
from him or he's suckling from her and then she eventually says, "Oh no, he's actually
taking it from my heart" and she's saying that here as well, Jesus said to her that
he suckled the love of his mother's heart and it was more love than milk that I suckled.
So while suckling, I would hear her say to me, I love you, I love you, my son and I would
repeat to her, I love you, I love you, my mother and I was not alone in this.
My, I love you, the Father and the Holy Spirit and the whole of creation, the angels, the
saints, the stars, the sun, the drops of water, the plants, the flowers, the grains of sand,
all the elements would run after my, I love you and repeat, we love you, we love you or
mother of our God in the love of our Creator, isn't that fantastic?
My mother could see all this, look at that, why?
So she's living in the divine will fully and would have remained inundated.
She could find, not even a tiny space in which she would not hear me say that I loved her.
Her love would remain behind and almost alone and she would repeat, "I love you, I love
you."
Now this goes on between Louisa and himself as well, but she could never match me.
Why?
Because she's a creature and he's the Creator.
Because the love of a creature has its limits and its time while mine is uncreated on ending
and eternal, that's Jeremiah 31-3, Jeremiah 31-3, Ephesians 3-19.
So the same happens to any soul, when she says to me, "I love you, I too repeat to her,
I love you."
And with me is the whole of creation loving her in my love.
That's Romans 8-19, Romans 8-19.
"Oh, if souls understood what good and honor they procure for themselves, even by just saying
to me, 'I love you,' this alone would be enough to have God beside them who honoring
them replies, 'I love you too.'"
That's your one Samuel 2-30 again, to also honor me, I will honor.
Okay, so December the 28th, 1908 we have earthquakes in Sicily and Calabria, that's in Italy.
So I want to give you Isaiah 46-10, 46-10, and Amos 3-7, "The Lord never does anything
without telling the prophets first," 3-7.
Joining myself in my usual state, I felt as if the earth were shaking, I wanted to slip
away from beneath us.
I was concerned and I said to myself, "Lord, Lord, what's this?"
And he said, "Earthquakes," well, I think it's funny about this and why I'm laughing
is she's in bed, she can't go anywhere, she feels the earth shaking under her, she actually
feels the earthquake, and she says, "Lord, what is it?"
And he just says, "Earthquakes."
It was nothing, and then he remains silent.
I almost paid no attention to him, and within myself I continued my interior things when
all of a sudden, about five hours after the word of me smoking, I felt the earthquake
sensibly.
As soon as I felt at cease, I found myself outside of myself almost confused.
I could see harrowing things, but this site was immediately removed from me and I found
myself inside of a church, and he doesn't want her to get upset, you see, because he
has done this without telling her, you see.
So a young man clothed it in white came from the altar, I believe it was our Lord, but
I can't say it was certain, and then he said, "Come."
I shrugged my shoulders, Louisa said, "Without getting up, wonderful, isn't it?"
And calculating within me that at that hour he was scourging and destroying, I said, "Lord,
what do you want me for now?"
After refusing his invitation, and the young man threw himself into my arms, and in my
interior I heard him say, "Come, old daughter, that I may end it with the world, I will destroy
a great part of it with earthquakes, waters that's tsunamis and wars."
After this I found myself inside of myself, well that's a scary bit, isn't it?
So December the 30th, the infancy of Jesus divinizes the infancy of all.
This is the redoing of human nature, okay, so just put redoing there, redoing human nature.
I was meditating on the mystery of Jesus' infancy, and I said to myself, "My baby, to
how many pains you wanted to subject yourself, it was not enough for you to, was it not enough
for you to come as an adult?
You wanted to come as a baby, and you suffer from swaddling clothes, silence the immobility
of your little humanity, of your feet, your hands, why all this?"
When I was saying this, he moved in my interior, and he told me, "My daughter, my works are
perfect."
I wanted to come as a little infant in order to divinize all the sacrifices and all the
little actions of infancy.
What's the redoing of human beings?
When sin then, sorry, so until, this is wonderful, what he says here, "Until children begin
to commit sins, everything remains absorbed in my childhood and divinized by me."
Now next time you look at an infant, just realize that all their actions are divinized
in him and absolutely incredible.
When sin then begins, separation begins between me and that person, the separation which is
sorrowful for me and mournful for them.
And Louisa said, "How can this be if babies don't have reason and are not capable of
deserving?"
And he answered, "First, because I give merit by my grace."
Very important information for aborted babies you've sent on to God, isn't it?
Secondly, because it's not out of their will that they do not want to deserve, but because
such is the state of infancy which is disposed by me anyway.
So it's God's will.
Besides, a gardener who has planted a plant is not only honored, but he also picks the
fruit of it, and even though the plant does not have reason.
And this is the same for the artisan who makes a statue and for many other things.
Sin alone, this is the gem now, you need to call her.
Sin alone is that which destroys everything and separates the human being from me.
But everything else, even the most trivial action comes to the souls from me and to me,
it returns with the mark of the honor of my creation.
Isn't that fantastic?
I want to give you several scriptures there.
Proverbs 14-34, Proverbs 14-34, Isaiah 50 verses 16-22, Isaiah 59 verse 2.
So now we want to January the second 1909, and again, Jesus tells you about earthquakes
and stuff.
So that's your Isaiah 46-10.
To my great repugnance and only to obey, I continue to say what happened from December
the 28th regarding the earthquake, because remember she said she actually felt it.
I was thinking to myself about the lot of so many poor people alive under the rocks,
and about the lot of my lord in the sacrament.
You see, in 1909 they wouldn't have had the same ability to lift people from under rocks
as they do now, and also about the lot of my lord in the sacrament.
He too alive and buried under the rubble, so obviously churches were destroyed.
I said to myself, it seems as if the lord is saying to these people, "I have the same
lot as you because of your sins.
I am together with you to help you, to give you strength.
I love you so much that I am waiting for one last act of love to save you all, not taking
into account all the evil that you've done in the past.
Am I good?
My life and my all?
I send you my adoration under the rubble wherever you are, and my embraces and kisses and with
all my powers to keep you continuous company.
Oh, how I wish I could come and dig you out to put you in a more comfortable place and
more worthy of you.
Now the answer she gets back from him is a terrible shock for her.
At that moment, my adorable Jesus told me in my interior, "My daughter, you have somehow
interpreted the excesses of my love," notice the somehow, not completely, which even while
scourging I send to the people, in other words, God's love never ceases, but this isn't all,
there's more.
Know that my sacramental lot is perhaps less unhappy, less nauseating under the rocks than
in the tabernacles.
Isn't that a bit frightening?
The number of sacrileges committed by priests, and also by the people, is such that I'm tired
of descending into their hands and into their hearts, to the point of being forced to destroy
almost all of them.
Oh dear, I want to give you a revelation, 1118, I think it is, I will destroy the destroyers
of the earth, 1118.
And then, what about the ambition and the scandals of priests?
God, this was not only 1909, this is more than a century later.
Everything was darkness in them, he said.
They were no longer the light of the world that they were supposed to be.
That's Matthew 517, you're the light of the world, Matthew 517.
And when priests reached the point of no longer giving out light, the people reach the excesses,
that is of evil, and my justice is forced to destroy them.
We're seeing that today, aren't we?
So that's why there's no way out of justice, isn't it?
I was also thinking about his privations, Louisa said, and I felt a fear in me, as if
some strong earthquake was about to happen here, that's in Corrata.
In seeing myself so alone without Jesus, I felt so oppressed as to feel I was dying.
Then having compassion for me, good Jesus came like a shadow, and he told me, my daughter,
do not oppress yourself so much, out of regard for you, I will spare this city most grave
damages.
Isn't that incredible?
So I want to give you Isaiah 49, 16, one who stands in the breach.
Since see, if I should not continue to chastise, instead of converting, of surrendering, that
is surrendering to the divine will, in hearing of the destruction of other provinces, they
say that it is those places and lands that make this happen, and they take their own
good time continuing to offend me.
You'll find that also referenced in, I think it's Revelation 16, but I don't remember
exactly what the verse is.
What it says in Revelation 16 is that, for the people who didn't experience the chastisements,
they continued on with all their evil.
How blind and foolish they are, it is the whole earth, is the whole earth not in the
palm of my hand, okay, that's a song of songs to 16, we're in the palm of his hand.
Try perhaps not to open chasms in the earth and cause them to be swallowed up in other
places as well.
Now, I would just say, CF Exodus, because you remember Dathan and Beulam in Exodus, the
earth opened up and swallowed them up for their rebellion against God.
And to show them this, I will cause earthquakes in other places which they usually do not
occur.
Now, there's also a reference in Isaiah for that, that I will have to show you signs
that you won't be able to say, we've seen all this before.
So while saying this, he seemed to stretch out his hand into the center of the earth,
taking some fire and moving it closer to the surface of the earth, and the earth would
shake and the earthquake would be felt.
Some places more intensely and other places less and he added.
This is only the beginning of chastisements, what will be the end of them?
Well, you go to the book of Revelation for that, and there's three huge movements of
chastisements from chapter 8, 9 and 10, and chapter 16, the three movements.
So January the 8th, 1909, the fruit and the purpose of Holy Communion.
You received Communion at the best moment.
I was thinking of how I could cling to blessed Jesus more than ever.
And he said to me, in order to cling more tightly to the point of dissolving your being
in mine, that's John 14, 20 to 21, and Saint Paul also says for me to live is Christ.
Just as I transfuse mine into yours, you must take what is mine in everything.
And in everything, leave what is yours.
You see, we're not allowed any baggage, that's the problem.
And we have no idea how much baggage we have until we start shifting some of it.
Have you ever tried clearing out your house and you thought you were doing really well
and it got us a few more rooms as well, and the more you do one place, the more there
is to be done.
That's the awful thing about doing something in your house.
So it's the same spiritually as well.
You know, you're really making an effort and then you realize it's more and more and more
and more.
He wants everything to go, okay?
We're not allowed any baggage.
So you should leave what is yours in such a way that if you always think of things which
are holy and regard only what is good and the honor and glory of God, you leave your
mind and take the divine.
In other words, you stop your human machinations in your thinking and you take on a divine
way of thinking.
When you stop loving in a human way, you take on a divine way of loving.
When you stop just a human way of being, you take on a divine way of being.
If you speak, if you operate good and only out of love for God, you leave your mouth
and your hands and you take my mouth and you take my hands.
That's where the healing hands comes from.
If you walk along holy and upright paths, you will walk with my own feet.
If your heart loves me more, you will leave your heart and you will take mine and you
will love me with my own love.
That's the only love that's useful to him because it's divine and so with all the rest.
So you will be enveloped with all of my things and I with all of yours.
We give him what we can't keep in order to receive what we can't lose.
It's fantastic, isn't it?
We give him what we can't keep in order to receive from him what we can't lose.
So Jesus said, "Can there be a tighter union than this?"
Yeah, "If the soul reaches the point of no longer recognizing herself, but the divine
being within her, these are the fruits of good communions."
Wow, you're supposed to be sanctified with them.
Galatians 2.20 "Now Saint Therese of Lesus said that she was aware of growing in holiness
every time she received communion."
I find that astonishing to you.
So, "And this is the divine purpose in wanting to communicate himself to souls.
In other words, to transform us into himself and to divinize us.
But how frustrated my love remains and how few are the fruits that souls gather from
this sacrament to the point," look at this, "that the majority of them remains indifferent
and even nauseated by this divine food."
Isn't that incredible?
So I want to give you Numbers 21.5.
Numbers 21.5.
It says we are sick of this unsatisfying food.
Okay?
"So, January 22, 1909, when God is the debtor of the soul, I was thinking about the many
privations of our Lord and about the fact that once years ago, after I had waited for
our Lord for a few hours, when He came, I lamented to Him, for He had made me struggle
so much for His coming, and then He told me, "My daughter, when I surprise you, anticipating
your yearnings for me, and I come without having you wait, then you're in my debt.
You're my debtor."
But when I have you wait for some time, and I become your debtor, or Louisa's not going
to let him off with this ever, she's going to remind him, "This is ammunition that is
given her, because she'll tell him, 'You're in my debt, you've got to pay your debt.'"
And do you think it's trivial to have that God gives you the occasion to make Him your
debtor?
You see, people at our level wouldn't know why the force was being made, but at our level
it's huge, okay?
And Louisa said, "I was saying to myself, at that time it was ours, and now it's days.
Who knows how many debts He has made with me?
I believe they are innumerable, because He has been having many of these whims."
Look at the way she's talking about Him, He's real to her, isn't He?
But then I thought to myself, "What's the good of me having God as a debtor?
I believe to have Him as a debtor, or to be His debtor is the same for Jesus, because
in one instant He can give so much to the soul as to equal and surpass the debts He has,
and so here's how the debts are canceled."
So she sort of writing it off, okay?
Well, when I was thinking of this, blessed Jesus told me, "My daughter, you're speaking
nonsense."
In one number one, in addition to the spontaneous gifts that I give to souls, there are number
two gifts of bond.
This is a new language.
To the souls of the spontaneous gifts, I may give or may not, it's my choice, because
no bond binds me, but with the souls, with the gifts of bond, as in your case, I am bound
and forced to give them what they want, and to grant them my gifts.
Imagine a gentleman and two persons.
One of these two keeps his money in the hands of the gentleman while the other doesn't.
The gentleman may give to both one and the other, but which one is more sure to obtain
in a circumstance of need?
The one who has the money in the hands of the gentleman or the one who doesn't?
Certainly the one who has the money will have all the good dispositions, the courage, the
confidence to go and ask for what is deposited in the hands of that gentleman.
And if he sees him hesitant in giving, he will say to him, "Frankly, you better give
it to me and quickly," because indeed, I'm not asking you for what is yours but what
is mine.
On the other hand, if the other one goes, who has nothing deposited in the hands of the
gentleman, he will go timidly and without confidence, and it will be up to the gentleman
whether he wants to give him some help or not.
This is the difference that passes between when I am the debtor and when I'm not.
If you could understand what immense goods are produced by having a credit with me, he's
trying to get her to somehow grasp what he's saying, but initially she wasn't.
So Louisa said, "I add that while I was writing, I was thinking to myself, 'Oh, some more nonsense.'
When I am in heaven, my dear Jesus, you will feel irritated for having made so many debts
with me.'
Well, if you come now, since I become your debtor, you who are so good at the first encounter
we will have will cancel all the debts.
In other words, she says, 'If you're full of debts, why don't you just come now and
you can pay them all.'
That's no problem to me.
The problem is when you stay away.
But I who am bad will not let it go and will demand payment for even a breath of waiting.
Wow, this is eight volumes later, isn't it?
That's a lot of debt, isn't it?
For every breath.
But while I was thinking of this, he told me in my interior, my daughter, 'I will not
feel irritation but contentment because my debts are debts of love.'
That's Romans 13 verses 1 to 2, Romans 13, let all your debts be debts of love Paul says.
And I desire to be the debtor more than to have you as my debtor.
In fact, these debts which I make with you, while being debts for me, will be pledges
and treasures which I will keep in my heart for eternity and which will give you the right
to be loved by me more than others.
This will be one more joy and glory for me.
And you will be repaid for even a breath, a minute, a desire, a heartbeat, and the more
pressing and greedy you will be in demanding, the more pleasure you will give me and the
more I will give you.
Do you remember he promised for any of us who would follow him that you'd get the 100%
in houses, I don't know how that works, and in everything else that he gave up for him?
So he says, 'Are you happy now?'
Okay, so January 27, 1909, 'Continue in my usual state, I said to myself what a useless
life mine is.
After all of this, she comes round to what a useless life this is.
What good do I do?
Everything's over.
There's no more sharing of thorns, crosses, and nails.
It seems that everything is exhausted.
I do feel suffering to the point that I cannot move.
It is a general rheumatism of pain, but it's something all natural.
Now he has explained it to passages back.
All of this explains it in great detail and she's back to where she was.
That doesn't happen to you, does it?
It takes human beings a lot before they can actually grasp something new that's said
to them.
I'm sure you've said to people, and particularly children or anyone that you are trying to
train, but I told you that ten times already, how many more ways do I have to say it before
you hear it?
That's the way we are.
That's why we have to keep studying this stuff, because if you take it all in in one
reading, a congratulations.
Louisa is not really aware that he is gradually turning her to a new vocation.
This is volume eight, and by volume eleven she's in her new vocation, which is to start
the kingdom of the divine will.
She doesn't have to continue being the victim soul once she's really into it.
She's in this interim phase and she doesn't understand.
I'm only left with the continuous thought of the passion, she said, and the union of
my will with that of Jesus, offering what he suffered and all of myself as he wants for
whoever he wants.
But apart from this, there's nothing but squalad, misery.
Very interesting description of her life, isn't it?
There was the purpose of my life.
When I was thinking of this blessed Jesus came, he has to come when she goes into this
kind of nonsense.
And he says, "My daughter, do you know who you are?
Louisa of the Passion of the Tabernacle."
He gives her this title.
When I share my pains with you, you are still of Calvary.
When I don't, you are of the Tabernacle.
See how true this is in the Tabernacle, I show nothing on the outside, neither crosses nor
thorns, and yet my immolation is the same as on Calvary.
The prayers are the same, the offering of my life still continues.
My will has not changed in any way.
I burn with thirst for the salvation of souls.
I can say that the things of my sacramental life united with those of my mortal life are
always at one point.
They have decreased in nothing.
However, everything is interior.
This is the way he is trying to say to her, he is gearing her now to a completely interior
life.
It will have none of the external.
So if your will is the same as when I used to share my pains, notice I used to share
my pains, she is in the transition time.
If your offerings are similar, if your interior is united with me, with my will, am I not
right in saying that you are at Louisa of the Passion of the Tabernacle?
With this difference, that when I share my pains with you, you take part in my mortal
life that is at extra, and I spear the world the gravest scourges.
When I do not share them with you, I scourge the world, and you take part in my sacramental
life, but the life is always one.
That is interesting.
So January 28, 1909, he is talking about victim souls.
Having read a book that talked about the different ways of operating interior, he is talking
about interior life that she reads a book about it, and about how Jesus would compensate
these souls with the great capital of grace and with super abundant love, which he has
already told her anyway.
I compared everything I had read to the many ways and the different acts that Jesus has
taught me in my interior, which compared to those in the book seemed to me to be so vast
as the sea compared to a little river.
I said to myself, "If this is true, who knows how much grace might always love about Jesus
pours into me, and how much love he has for me?"
Then as I found myself in my usual state, good Jesus came for just a little, and he told
me, "My daughter, you do not yet know well what it means to be chosen as a victim soul."
Just as I, by being a victim soul, enclosed in myself all the acts of creatures, their
satisfactions, reparations, adorations, and thanksgivings, in such a way that I did for
all and for each one that which they were supposed to do.
In the same way, since you are a victim soul, it is useless to compare yourself to others
because he's been telling her for eight volumes that she's to be a copy of him.
She's not to look at other people.
You must enclose within you not the way of one but the variety of the ways of each one,
and since I must have you make up for all and for each one as a consequence, I must give
you not the grace that I give to one person, but as much grace to equal what I give to
the whole of humanity.
That's unbelievable, isn't it?
Therefore, love too must surpass all the love that I give to everybody else because grace
and love go together.
That's 1 John 4, 7 to 21, 1 John 4, 7 to 21.
Grace and love must go together.
They have one single step, one single measure and one single will.
Love draws grace and grace draws love there inseparable because grace and love are both
God.
So this is why you see the most extensive sea which I have placed in you and the little
rivers and others.
So Louisa said I remained astounded comparing much grace to so much in gratitude and badness
in me.
Okay.
So we're coming to the end of this particular section and we finished with January the
30th, 1909 and the amazing thing is it's called the story of why.
Okay.
You'd be very surprised what he says about why because my memory of childhood is a child
saying why, no matter what the adult says, the child says why because they're in the
process of learning but an adult saying is different.
Why does the good God do that to me?
And we close the fist.
That why is a problem.
The why of the infant, the small child who's in a learning process about everything, thereby
is completely different.
Okay.
So it's our adult why is the problem.
Finding myself in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself and I seem to see
a soul in purgatory whom I knew and I said to her, take a look at how I am before God.
I find this fascinating.
If you saw a soul in purgatory, surely our first thing is to go and pray for the poor
creature.
And instead of that, Louisa said, no, I want you to do it.
It just certainly went down late.
This is a fascinating take a look at how I am before God.
She said, I'm so concerned about it, especially about the state in which I find myself.
And the soul told me it takes nothing to know whether you're doing well or badly.
If you appreciate suffering, you're doing well.
If you don't, you're doing badly.
That's a soul in purgatory who have learned that suffering is the way to get to heaven.
Isn't that fascinating?
God, nobody on earth would say that would they?
In fact, one who appreciates suffering appreciates God because suffering has become the way to
purify in cleansers.
And by appreciating him, you can't displease him.
Things which are appreciated are also esteemed and loved and one cherishes them and keeps
them safe more than oneself.
Can it ever be possible that one wants evil for himself?
In the same way, it's impossible that one may displease God if he appreciates him.
Then afterwards, blessed Jesus came for just a little, and he told me, my daughter.
In almost all of the events that occur, people keep repeating over and over again.
Why?
Why this illness?
Why this interior state?
This is God.
So many whys.
The explanation of why is not written on earth but in heaven, and it's there, everyone will
read it.
Do you know what why is?
It is egoism, he said, which gives continuous food to the love of self.
Do you know why was created in hell?
Who was the first to pronounce it, a demon?
The effects produced by the first why were the loss of innocence in Eden itself, and
the war of untamed passions, the ruin of many souls, the evils of life.
The story of why Islam is enough to tell you that there's no evil in the world which
does not carry the mark of why.
It's not interesting.
Why is the destruction of divine wisdom in souls?
You see, under why there, he's actually covering in a very, very simple way this whole problem
of rationalism and humanism and all the rest of it that destroys a godly way of thinking.
So that's why he says that why is the destruction of divine wisdom in souls?
And do you know where a why will be buried in hell to make them restless for eternity
without ever giving them any peace?
The art of why is to wage war against souls without ever giving them respite.
Is that something else?
So I want to leave it there, and that's the end of Volume 8.